you talked about the doors two guys for
the pelicans and zion and
ingram that want to learn and want to be
coached hard
as luca hits the mid-range jump shot but
it's not just him you know it was so
fascinating talking to
to rick carlisle earlier today and he
mentioned this a season ago as
conscience puts it on the deck gets a
nice drive
excited he is by the way the game is
played mark
yeah and to work with some of these
young big guys too
as luca drains the three
might be in his own but i'm one on one
and my speed is going to be a factor
here
luca hits another mid-range shot can get
some momentum downhill
and now you got jj reddick checking it's
interesting doors sometimes you almost
feel that luca might
be bailing out his defenders by settling
for as many threes as he shoots when he
gets into the lane like that
man he makes it look easy all right
you're a little bit undersized for me
josh hart an excellent individual
defense
doncic has talked about being a better
defender this year as he got a
free pass to the basket for the layup
adam switches on to luca
see what i'm talking about with his
footwork in the paint mark
luca with the step back got it down by
three doncic with adam switched on to
him
little machine gun dribble three ball on
the way
got it 16-3 of the night so they're
over the average that the pelicans
normally give
leba really frustrated him at the
offensive end
and had five block shots on zion luca
with the step back
27 for he and 27 for porzingis that's
easy
[Music]
[Applause]
good show on defense by williamson luca
has the three working
and another one doncic back in the ball
game for the mavericks
[Applause]
picked up by hernan gomez
[Applause]
a little hesitation move got all the way
to the basket
[Applause]
and a quiet night for tim hardaway
junior at the offensive end
doncic has had it growing and that's why
uh
already has one first team all nba
underneath this belt
and louis a step slow winston has done a
nice job
here's doncic guarded by heart art
fights around the screen
doncic spins on a dime and no change for
the pelicans
so herodon gomez goes to meet him but
the footwork
yeah good point of course 26 on the
night but a lot of those points coming
early luca with the midi
got it and on the other end
brandon ingram's checking them but the
breaks right
williamson on luca again
good defense by williamson but a better
fake by luca
on in the paint and all the work he does
well this guy's not too shabby either
he averages over 12. he's doing work in
there tonight
7 and 14.
doncic get into the paint
and off glass yeah putting some muscle
in his hustle he flexed on the pelicans
a little bit